Ja, okay.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Schachin. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzärztin tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie mich jederzeit unterbrechen. Sind Sie am Teil verstanden?
Ja.
Zunächst benötige ich Ihre persönliche Daten. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin Maya Georg.
Okay, können Sie es kurz buchstabieren?
Okay. M-A-I-E-R und mein Name ist G-E-O-R-G.
Herr Gok, denke ich, ist ein Mann. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 34 Jahre alt.
Wie ist Ihre Geburtstatum?
Meine Geburtstatum ist 17. April, 92.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Gok?
Ich bin 1 Meter 80 und wiege 68 Kilo.
Wie heißt Ihre Hausarztin?
Herr Groner.
Was führt Sie heute zu uns, Herr Gok?
Frau Doktor, ich habe seit 4 Tagen einen Flecken in meinem Wein.
Einen was haben Sie?
Flecken.
Okay.
Und jeden Tag ist das ein bisschen vergrößert.
Ja.
Zudem habe ich Fieber, Frau Doktor.
Seit wann haben Sie Fieber? Seit 4 Tagen, oder?
Ja, genau. Seit 4 Tagen.
Haben Sie es gemessen?
Ja, ich habe es gemessen. Das ist 38 Celsius.
38 Grad, seit 4 Tagen. Haben Sie schon etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe ein paar Mal Epiprosthetamol eingenommen.
Ja, das hilft mir ein bisschen.
Okay. Wann haben Sie am letzten Mal eingenommen?
Gestern.
Okay. Also haben Sie nur eine Fleck oder viele Flecken bemerkt?
Ich habe nur eine gesehen.
Wo liegt es? Ganz genau. Sie haben nur Bein gesagt. Aber welche Beine? Unterschenkel, Oberschenkel, hinten, vorne?
Ja, das liegt an meinem linken Unterschenkel.
Am linken Unterschenkel. Okay.
Es vergrößert sich seit 4 Tagen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Hautveränderungen bemerkt?
Rötung oder Bläschengrötung, Guckreiz, Haarauffall?
Nein, ich habe keine Guckreiz oder Schmerzen. Aber das ist ein bisschen am Rand rot.
Es ist dunkelrot am Rand.
Ja, genau.
Und in der Mitte?
In der Mitte ein heller Rötung.
Okay. Am Rand ist es rot und in der Mitte ist es heller.
Ja, heller.
Okay. Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie keine Schmerzen haben. Fühlen Sie an der betroffenen Seite Krippen oder Talpeitsgefühle?
Nein.
Seit 4 Tagen haben Sie diese Flecke. Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser? Kann es sein, dass Sie von einem Insekt gestochen sind?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Allerdings habe ich erst mal vor 2 Wochen bemerkt.
Damals war ich im Wald. Ich habe eine Wanderung gemacht. Aber damals habe ich nur eine kleine Rötung gesehen.
Ich habe nicht gesehen, ob von einem Insekt oder anderen Säcken.
Okay. Eigentlich haben Sie diese Flecke als Rötung vor 2 Wochen bemerkt.
Aber seit 4 Tagen ist es sehr groß und ist größer geworden.
Ja, meine Fieber hat angefangen.
Okay. Fühlen Sie, dass auch die betroffene Seite überwärmt ist?
Nein.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie seit 4 Tagen Fieber haben. Leiden Sie auch unter Nachschweiß oder Schüttelfrost?
Nein. Ich habe keine Schüttelfrost. Aber es ist mir aufgefallen. Ich habe auch alle Muskelschmerzen.
Was haben Sie?
Grisschmerzen oder Krenkschmerzen.
An welche Gelenke?
An allen Gelenken.
Fühlen Sie auch Muskelkrämpfe, Muskelschwäche oder Muskelschmerzen?
Ich habe nur Muskelschmerzen. Ich habe keine Muskelschwäche, aber Muskelschmerzen.
Muskelschmerzen und Gelenkeschmerzen. Fühlen Sie seit 4 Tagen oder länger?
Seit 4 Tagen. Aber ich habe auch Kopfschmerzen.
Auch seit 4 Tagen?
Ja. Normalerweise habe ich Mikrohren. Aber diese Schmerzen sind unterschiedlich.
Sie denken, dass diese Kopfschmerzen mit dem Fieber zusammen verbunden sind?
Ja.
Das ist nicht eine Mikrohren-Kopfschmerzen.
Wie ist es? Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Das ist normal.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein. Ich habe keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Atemnot, Husten, Herzrasen, Herzstolpern, solche Beschwerden?
Nein.
Haben Sie etwas zusätzliches für die Kopfschmerzen oder Muskelschmerzen eingenommen?
Ja. Ich habe nur Palästermal eingenommen.
Sonst nichts?
Sonst nichts.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie an Mikrohren leiden. Seit wie vielen Jahren?
Seit fünf Jahren.
Nehmen Sie etwas dagegen regelmäßig ein?
Nur bei Bedarf nehme ich Tomat-Triptin.
Ok. Tomat-Triptin.
Ja.
Leiden Sie noch an anderen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja. Ich habe auch Ruckerkrankheit.
Seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren. Kann man sagen, dass es ein Tipp 1 ist?
Ja. Genau.
Sie wissen es schon.
Deshalb muss ich jeden Tag in einem Schiff gehen.
Ok. Und?
Insulin seit 20 Jahren. Und noch etwas?
Ja. Manchmal nehme ich Aspirin. Aber nun bei Bedarf.
Also als Schmerzmittel nehmen Sie Aspirin?
Ja. Genau.
Sie leiden an Mikrohren und eine Zuckerkrankheit. Tipp 1.
Und leiden Sie sonst noch an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Ok. Super. Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein. Ich wurde nicht operiert worden.
Ok. Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein, außer die genannten Medikamente?
Nein.
Ok. Ist bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Nein. Ich habe keine Allergien.
Oder irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein.
Brauchen Sie Herr Gork?
Ja. Ich brauche seit 10 Zigaretten jeden Tag.
Seit wieviel Jahren?
Ca. 20 Jahre.
Trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Manchmal. Vielleicht ein Glas.
Ok. Also kann man gelegentlich sagen?
Ja.
Was trinken Sie meistens? Bier? Wein?
Nein. Ich bekomme sie nur Wein.
Ich habe noch eine Frage an Sie, Herr Gork.
Aber bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich an.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein. Wir haben nicht probiert.
Sie haben nicht probiert. Ok.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Leider, Frau Doktor. Ich mache nicht so viel Sport.
Ok. Ich kann es verstehen. Man hat ja auch nicht so viel Zeit für Sport.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja. Ich bin in meinem Haus regelmäßig geimpft.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein. Nein, Frau Doktor. Ich muss arbeiten.
Ich habe nicht so viel.
Ja, ich kann es verstehen.
Ist in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja. Ich habe eine Schwester und sie hat ein Darm-Syndrom.
Ach so. Es tut mir leid zu hören.
Danke schön.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein. Nein. Wir sind ganz gelungen.
Super. Toll. Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Gork?
Nein. Ich denke nicht.
Ok. Leben Sie alleine oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich lebe mit meiner Familie zusammen.
Ich muss auch meine Schwester kümmern.
Ich verstehe. Und ich nehme an, dass Sie auch keine Kinder haben.
Genau.
Was machen Sie als beruflich?
Ich arbeite im Markt.
Im Alt. Ok. Kann ich sagen Kassirer?
Ja. Ich arbeite im Kassir oder im Tracke oder im Gürtel oder Zahe.
Ok. Supermarkt-Arbeiter.
Genau.
Das ist eine sehr stressige Arbeit. Sie müssen auf die Zähne schauen.
Ich möchte noch etwas fragen. Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie keine Schmerzen haben.
Aber können Sie Ihre betroffenen Beine bewegen?
Ja. Ich kann bewegen.
Sie haben keine Probleme mit der Bewegung?
Nein.
Sie haben alle Schmerzen, aber nicht alle Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
6, 7.
Die Gelenkschmerzen und die Muskelschmerzen.
Ok.
Das waren meine Fragen. Herr Georg, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein. Ich möchte nicht etwas hinzufügen. Aber was kann sein? Ich fühle mich sehr müde.
Das kann ich verstehen. Die Angaben bedeuten am ehesten eine Infektion.
Sie haben ja eine rote Fleck bemerkt.
Es kann sein, dass Sie von einem Insekt oder einer Zecke gestochen sind.
Es kann sein. Aber natürlich werden wir es untersuchen.
Wenn wir die Erreger feststellen können, dann werden wir die Therapie durchführen.
Die Angaben bedeuten am ehesten eine Infektion. Wir werden tun, was wir machen können.
Wir werden unser Bestes machen.
Danke schön. Frau Doktor, können Sie mir eine Krankheitsschreibung schreiben?
Ja, natürlich. Das können wir machen. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen darüber.
Ok.
Wir sehen uns gleich noch mal.
Frau Doktor, können Sie mir Wasser bringen?
Ja, wir können Sie jetzt ein Glas Wasser bringen. Kein Problem. Die Schleister werden wir bringen.
Hat jemand andere Fragen?
Ja.
Herr Georg, können Sie Ihre Glied- und Muskelschmerzen beschreiben? Sie stehen dunkel.
Ja, ich kann dunkel Schmerzen sagen.
Ok. Jetzt haben Sie Fieber und Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe Schmerzen und Fieber.
Wann haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ich misse jeden Tag. Mindestens zweimal, dreimal.
Wo messen Sie?
Im Ohr habe ich gemessen.
Ok.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Husten?
Ich habe keine Atemnot, aber ich habe auch ein bisschen Schluckbechwerde.
Schluckbechwerde?
Ja.
Ok.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Wieder sind sie vor vier Tagen aufgetreten.
Ok. Gibt es ein besonderes Essen oder Fest oder Wäsche?
Ja, Fest oder Wäsche kann ich nicht einpassen.
Ok. Haben Sie Halsschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe auch ein bisschen Halsschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie auch?
Sie sind auch seit vier, fünf Tagen.
Sind Sie müde abgeschlagen?
Ja, ich bin sehr müde.
Haben Sie Herzschmerzen?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit? Ich habe meine Kollegen gefragt.
Das ist normal.
Ok. Vielen Dank.
Sie haben eine Frage.
Was ist Ihr Name?
Mein Name ist Maya.
Ich habe es mir vorgestellt.
Du kannst auch Türkische Namen benutzen.
Das kann ich machen.
Es gibt auch Arabische Namen in einigen Fällen.
Ja, das kann sein.
In KPs benutzt man auch Türkische und Arabische Namen.
Sie machen die Körner, die auf die Körner liegen.
Die Körner.
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerde?
Nein.
Ich habe sehr viel Erschädigung.
Aber mit so einer Flanke hatte ich keine.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden langsam oder akut aufgetreten?
Entschuldigung?
Langsam oder plötzlich?
Ich habe die Erschmerzen für die ersten zwei Wochen gesehen.
Aber andere sind schon später und langsam begonnen.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen auch Ihre Fieber?
Ich habe die Fieber aber nicht.
Ich habe die Fieber nicht.
Aber ich habe die Fieber nicht.
Okay.
Vielen Dank für die Antwort.
Danke.
Wenn du das alles getestet hast, was hast du?
Ich habe es mir in der Hand gehalten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es hier eine FSM-Achung gibt.
Muss ich das fragen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe die FSM-Achung von vielen Ansefaliten.
Ansefaliten.
Muss ich das fragen?
Ich glaube, nicht.
Aber wenn man es fragt, ist es gut.
Denn wir kennen uns schon.
Ich habe in unseren Berichten etwas geschrieben.
Es ist gut.
Es ist ein Freund, der etwas zu hören hat.
Sie schreiben ja auch nach dem Test.
Aber es ist in uns geschaffen, ein bis zwei Mal.
Nein, es ist in uns geschaffen.
Es ist nicht in uns geschaffen.
Muth hat es natürlich besser.
Aber ich erinnere mich, dass sie etwas zu hören haben.
Das ist eine verursachliche Ansefalite.
Ich verstehe.
Oder vielleicht noch länger.
Bis zum Schutz geht es nicht lange.
Es geht um drei Jahre.
Ja, es ist nicht ein Jahr.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es zwei bis drei Jahre lang dauert.
Ich habe die Füße neu kontrolliert.
Ich habe keine Tetanose, keine Hepatit A, keine Füße.
Sie kontrollieren die ganzen Füße, wenn sie anfangen.
Sie machen nichts zu verhindern.
Sie starten die Arbeit und dann gehen sie nach ihr.
Sie schreiben Karten.
Sie können es sich auch nach der Arbeit machen.
Ja, aber sie starten die Arbeit ohne die MMR-Achse.
Sie wollen direkt an die Füße.
Sie haben die Füße, aber sie haben keine Hepatit A.
Ich habe keine Füße, keine Tetanose.
Sie wollen die Hepatit B.
Aber sie haben keine Hepatit A.
Ich habe keine Hepatit A.
Ich habe keine Füße, habe keine Füße.
Sie schauen nicht auf die Routine.
Sie schauen auf die Hepatit B.
Ohne Füße? Okay.
Ich habe die Füße kontrolliert.
Sie schauen nicht auf die Hepatit A.
Okay, super.
Sie haben die Hepatit A.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das muss sein.
Aber es ist in der Kindheit.
Es ist eine positive EGG.
Es ist nicht eine Routine.
Okay, ich werde nicht zu viel ausbreiten.
Ja, ich werde nicht zu viel ausbreiten.
Okay, können Sie das machen?
Das ist die Zeit.
Hallo, guten Tag, Herr Dr. Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne vorstellen, falls Sie Zeit haben.
Ja, natürlich.
Der 43-jährige Herr Meier-Georg ist 1,80 Meter groß und wiegt 68 kg.
Herr Meier hat sich vor zwei Wochen aufgetreten.
Seit vier Tagen hat er sich vergrößert.
Er hat sich eine rote Fläche am linken Unterschenkel vorgestellt.
Er beschreibt die Fläche.
Es gab nur eine Fläche.
Rot am Rand und heller Rot in der Mitte.
Außerdem erwähnt er, dass er seit vier Tagen am Ohr gemessen hat.
Seit vier Tagen hat er Fieber.
Er hat 38 Grad Fieber.
Er hat die Fieber am Ohr gemessen und Paracetamol dagegen genommen.
Er hat nur eine Fläche.
Wie groß ist die Fläche?
Die Größe habe ich nicht gefragt.
Aber er hat schon berichtet, dass die Fläche sich seit vier Tagen vergrößert habe.
Erst ist die Fläche vor zwei Wochen aufgetreten.
Es handelt sich um einen dunkelroten flachen Ring mit hellem Zentrum.
Am Rand ist es rot und am Zentrum ist es heller rot.
Wie bitte?
Was begriffen Sie?
Es sah aus.
Wie bitte?
Wie können Sie diese Fläche nennen?
Als Fachbegriff?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Erzähl mal Migrant.
Also nur diese Fläche oder alle rote Flächen?
Nein.
Ein spezifischer Name.
Um einen dunkelroten flachen Ring mit hellem Zentrum.
Das bedeutet Erithoma Migrans.
Okay.
Vielen Dank. Das habe ich schon notiziert.
Schmerzhaft?
Nein.
Die Fragen nach Schmerz, Proritis, Hypesthesie, Parasthesie, Überwärmung wurden verneint?
Ukraïs, Schnupfung?
Wie bitte?
Gibt es Ukraïs und Schnupfung?
Nein, es gibt keine Brotveränderungen.
Okay, danke schön.
Außerdem habe ich den Patienten mitgeteilt, dass er seit vier Tagen unter Gelenkschmerzen und Kopfschmerzen leidet.
Er leidet unter dunkel Schmerzen und Gelenkschmerzen.
Langsam begonnen oder?
Langsam begonnen und dunkel Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen liegen bei 6-7 auf einer Skala von 0-10.
Hat er etwas aufgenommen?
Außer Paracetamol habe ich nichts aufgenommen.
Hat es ein paar Linderungen gebracht?
Ja, schon. Es hat nur ein bisschen Geholfen.
Er hat gleichzeitig Kopfschmerzen, Cephalgie.
Welche Charakter hat Kopfschmerzen?
Dunkelart, dunkel, schief?
Spezifisch nach Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht gefragt, aber der Potent hat seine Schmerzen als dunkel beschrieben.
Okay, gut.
Er hat auch unter Halsschmerzen Schluckbeschwerden seit 4-5 Tagen.
Die Fragen nach Schüttelfrost, nach Schweiß, Insomnie wurden verneint.
Sein Appetit sei normal.
Sein Appetit sei unauffällig, meinen Sie?
Ja, sein Appetit sei unauffällig bis auf 38 Grad Fieber.
Diese Beschwerden sind am ersten Mal betroffen.
Früher hatte er keine ähnlichen Beschwerden.
Vorerkrankungen? Ist das eine bekannte oder relevante Vorerkrankung?
Also, relevant kann das sein, warum nicht.
Als Vorerkrankung leidet er seit 5 Jahren mit Grenen und seit 20 Jahren mit Schmerzen.
Der Diabetes Militus Typ 1 kann zu einer Immunschwäche bringen.
Er wurde noch nie operiert.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf Aspirin ein.
Erlautungen sind bei ihm nicht bekannt.
Er raufe 10 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 20 Jahren.
Also 10 Packungbiers.
Er trinke gelegentlich Wein und habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Er treibe auch keinen Sport.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
In der Familienanamnese hat er ergeben, dass seine Schwester an Dantz-Syndrom leidet.
Er ist ledig. Er lebt mit seiner Familie und hat keine Kinder.
Er arbeitet als Supermarktangestellter.
Welche Wetterdiagnose haben Sie?
Die anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten als Kleimporhälios.
Er hat auch mitgeteilt, dass er vor zwei Wochen im Wald wandern gegangen ist.
Die Fläche ist erstmals vor zwei Wochen aufgetreten und hat sich in den letzten vier Tagen vergrößert.
Welche Differenzialdiagnose?
Als Differenzialdiagnose kann es erysipel sein.
Es kann auch periphere Arteriaverschlusskrankheit sein.
Es kann auch TVT sein.
Es kann auch eine Virale Infektion in Betracht kommen.
Was gehen Sie vor zur Ablehrung?
Als erstes würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen und die entzündlichen Parameter kontrollieren.
Ich werde auch eine Blutkultur machen, um die Erweckenheit zu beweisen.
Gibt es bestimmte Antikörper, um Leimborreliose zu bestätigen?
Ja, es gibt bestimmt eine.
Jede Infektion hat seine eigenen Antikörper.
Aber ich weiß die Name jetzt.
Aber dem Namen fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Okay.
Und im Minglopilien und im Minglopilien gegen Borrelia.
Welche Therapie möchten Sie einleiten?
Ich würde natürlich erst eine Flüssigkeit zuvor einleiten.
Also eine febersenkende Antiprätika werde ich verabreichen.
Wie bitte?
Symptomatische Therapie.
Ja, Symptomatische Therapie. Der Patient ist auch tostig.
Ich würde jetzt Flüssigkeit sofort, Antiprätika.
Und falls wir die Erreger nachweisen, würde ich mit Antibiotikatherapie anfangen.
Welche Antibiotika möchten Sie einleiten?
Welche Antibiotika?
Name also Penicillin?
Doxycycline.
Wenn es wirkt, kann es auch sein.
Könnten Sie bitte dem Patienten Erthema Migrans erklären?
Erklären Erthema Migrans.
Also Erthema Migrans ist doch die Flecke, die Erthema Migrans heißt.
Ja.
Okay.
Also Herr Gork, die Flecke, die Sie schon bemerkt und beschrieben haben, ist eine Erthema Migrans.
Erthema Migrans ist eine Flecke, die wir bei einer Infektion begegnen.
Die Ursache, die von einem Zeckenstich verursacht ist.
Zecken bis?
Zecken bis verursacht ist.
Ja, die eine von einem Zecken bis verursacht ist.
Lime Borreliosa?
Nein, die Erreger ist mir jetzt nicht eingefallen.
Borrelia buctorferi.
Ja, Borrelia buctorferi, die von einem Zecken bis übertragen ist.
Okay.
Brauchen wir bei Picham Erthema Migrans eine Labordeagnostik, um eine Therapie einzuleiten?
Also normalerweise würde ich die Labordeagnostik nicht warten.
Ich würde gleich mit der Biothektherapie anfangen.
Okay.
Also normalerweise würde ich das machen, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es in Deutschland geht.
Okay, gut. Wir brauchen die.
Es ist eine Chef-Lime Borreliosa.
Deswegen können wir schnell sofort eine Doktoksklinotherapie einladen.
Okay. Und Sie haben schon gesagt, eine Depressiadiagnose ist erzupro.
Und welche Charaktere hat erzupro?
Welche Charaktere hat erzupro? Also, weiß ich nicht.
Und welche Befunde gibt es, um erzupro auszuschließen oder zu bestätigen?
Also wahrscheinlich sehen die Flecken anders aus bei Erzipel.
Also soweit ich mich erinnern kann, ist bei Erzipel eine Fläche mit Rötung und schmerzhaftes und überwärmtes Flecken vorhanden.
Bei Erzipel.
Und?
Schmerzhaftes, überwärmtes und geschwollenes...
Scharfbegränsente...
Okay, scharfbegränsente Flecken vorhanden.
Flecken. Eine oder mehrere?
Eine.
Eine, okay. Eine Flecke ist vorhanden.
Okay. Und danke schön für die Vorstellung. Und wir können Doktoksklin einladen.
Und dann können wir vielleicht Labouruntersuchungen durchführen. Aber jetzt brauchen wir sie nicht.
Okay.
Ja, okay. Wir nehmen den Patienten natürlich stationär auf.
Ja, okay.
Das ist... Okay, vielen Dank.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Möchten wir hier mal etwas hinzufügen?
Hocam, war da was?
Hocam, ich habe eine Frage. Ich habe es nicht richtig verstanden.
Können wir ein Stück von der Rötung nehmen? Was wollt ihr? Okay, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Welche Erzipel-Folge wirst du ausfüllen oder welches Erzipel-Tanz wirst du?
Und wie ist das?
Ich habe es nicht richtig verstanden. Ich habe es nicht richtig verstanden.
Okay, was ist das? Welche Erzipel-Folge gibt es?
Also was ist die Unterschiede zwischen Erzipel und Erzipel?
Ihr könnt die Aufnahme aufhören.
Okay.
Nein, ich will das nicht sagen.